Німеччина останніми днями знову і знову вимушена вислуховувати критику за участь у суперечливому проєкті "Північний потік-2".
Так український прем'єр Денис Шмигаль під час нещодавнього візиту в Берлін, в інтерв'ю німецькому Handelsblatt
застеріг від посилення агресії Кремля у разі введення "Північного потоку-2" в експлуатацію.
За інформацією видання, Німеччина пропонує Україні механізми компенсації можливих втрат надходжень від транзиту газу.
І хоча на Німецько-українському економічному форумі за участі канцлерки Анґели Меркель дражлива тема не лунала,
на інших зустрічах без згадок про газопровід не обійшлося.
Випадом проти "Північного потоку-2" розпочав свій перший візит до Брюсселя і новий держсекретар США.
У штаб-квартирі НАТО Ентоні Блінкен закликав зупинити будівництво трубопроводу та нагадав у цьому зв'язку про інтереси України.
Президент Байден сказав дуже чітко: він переконаний, що газопровід – це погана ідея.
Погана для Європи, погана для Сполучених Штатів.
І зрештою вона суперечить власним цілям ЄС щодо енергетичної безпеки.
Вона ризикує зашкодити інтересам України, Польщі та інших близьких партнерів або союзників.
Німеччина вперто відкидає вимоги зупинити будівництво та екстериторіальні санкції США.
Уряд ФРН обґрунтовує необхідність проєкту тим, що нині потреби країни у газі збільшилися.
Рік тому Німеччина ухвалила рішення про відмову від вугільної енергетики на користь відновлювальних джерел енергії.
Тож газ нібито повинен зіграти роль перехідного енергоносія.
Німеччині буде потрібен газ на перехідний період. Ми бачимо це, наприклад, у сталеливарній промисловості.
Зробити її СО2-нейтральною не так просто. Для цього нам знадобиться дуже багато водню. Поки у нас його в достатній кількості немає.
Але важливо почати цей процес вже зараз. І газ - це та сировина, яка нам допоможе на перехідному етапі.
Але ми станемо свідками відмови і від газу.
І поки Держдепартамент США продовжує погрожувати санкціями усім компаніям, які беруть участь у проєкті,
будівництво Північного потоку-2"  завершено вже на понад 90 відсотків.
Як це можливо? Розслідування DW виявило можливі тіньові схеми.
Трубоукладач "Академік Черський" мав добудовувати другу нитку газопроводу "Північний потік" після того,
як через загрозу санкцій США від участі в проєкті відмовилась швейцарська компанія Allseas.
Однак судно прибуло в німецький порт Мукран на Балтійському морі погано підготовленим:
бракувало значної частини устаткування, необхідного для укладання труб.
І все ж, європейським компаніям вдалося дообладнати його новітньою технікою в обхід санкцій США.
За даними розслідування DW, дві італійські компанії, а також одна фірма з Нідерландів
постачали "Газпрому" через підставні фірми обладнання для трубоукладача, вартістю щонайменше близько 10 мільйонів доларів.
Перша лазівка ​​в американських санкціях - сума поставок.
Під санкції не підпадають товари і послуги вартістю менше мільйона доларів, або п'яти мільйонів доларів.
Так у вересні минулого року дочірня фірма "Газпрому", яка є власником трубоукладача "Академік Черський",
доставила в Німеччину верстати для обробки крайок труб і електрогідравлічні силові блоки виробництва італійської компанії Nuova Patavium.
Ось тільки партія верстатів, ввезена до Німеччини 12 вересня 2020 року, згідно з митною декларацією, коштувала понад мільйон доларів.
Чому ж чиновники у Вашингтоні цим не зацікавилися?
Виявилося, що італійці спочатку продали обладнання до Росії, двома партіями, і вказали вартість менше двохсот тисяч доларів кожна.
Питання DW про причини такої різниці у вартості в Nuova Patavium залишили без відповіді.
Друга лазівка ​​- підставні фірми. Компанія Nuova Patavium продала техніку для "Академіка Черського" не безпосередньо "Газпрому",
а компанії "Система-СПБ" з Санкт-Петербурга, в штаті якої лише три співробітника.
А ще одна італійська компанія - Opus S.R.L. - в серпні 2020 року поставила "Системі-СПБ"
елементи пневматичного центратора для автоматичного зварювання труб.
Через два тижні це обладнання прибуло до німецького порту Мукран вже як власність "дочки" "Газпром регіонгаз".
Обладнання з країн ЄС постачається не напряму отримувачам у Росії,
а якійсь компанії, яка незрозуміло звідки узялася і невідомо чим займається.
Наприклад, якійсь російській фірмі, яка займається обладнанням будинків пожежною безпекою.
І що вже далі з цим обладнанням відбувається, європейців не цікавить.
Обладнання є дуже специфічним - для укладання труб під водою. Саме газопроводів.
Куди в Росії буде ставитися це обладнання, здогадається будь-який школяр.
А особливо - зважаючи на увагу міжнародної спільноти до проєкту "Північний потік-2".
Утім, західні експерти, опитані DW, не вірять, що європейським фірмам вдалося обдурити американських чиновників.
Підключення до ланцюжка поставок компаній-пустишок не допоможе уникнути санкцій. І це не є безпечним виходом із ситуації.
Це все одно порушення. Це небезпечно і не захищає від санкцій.
Аналітик зі США Нікос Тсафос, своєю чергою, упевнений, що європейським постачальникам санкції насправді майже не загрожують.
США хотіли б зупинити цей проєкт. Однак Вашингтон не готовий зробити усе можливе для цього.
Я вважаю, що є межа, за яку США заходити не хочуть.
Вона полягає в тому, аби не надто сильно нашкодити відносинам з Європою і Німеччиною.
Схожої думки дотримується і політолог з Австрії.
Наразі уряд США та Джо Байден прагнуть поліпшити відносини з Німеччиною, які сильно постраждали під час правління Дональда Трампа.
Йдуть переговори і про "Північний потік-2" і можливі компромісні рішення за цим проєктом.
Тож я не очікую нових санкцій проти "Північного потоку-2" в найближчому майбутньому.
Водночас німецький аналітик Ганс-Геннінг Шредер каже, що на тлі погіршення американо-російських відносин
прогнозувати майбутнє "Північного потоку- 2" складно.
Я скажу обережно: офіційні представники Німеччини і німецькі компанії зараз ведуть у Конгресі велику роботу з лобіювання
та намагаються переконати Конгрес, ну, якщо не скасувати санкції, то хоча б більш обережно підходити до цього питання.
Матимуть успіх ці спроби чи ні, я не знаю.
Але, зазначає експерт, в ситуації, коли в США наростає негативне ставлення до Росії,
зупинити санкції, які загрожують у тому числі і німецьким компаніям, може не вийти.